président sortant donc ils sont
largement qui sortirait en tout cas
largement vainqueur au second tour
devant le candidat et rennes sébastien
chez nous chenu et la tête de liste de
l'union de la gauche karima delli sion
absolument samantha sa menace de quitter
définitivement la politique en cas de
défaite aux élections régionales aura eu
l'effet escompté puisque elle aura
permis et bien de rassembler son
électorat et xavier bertrand puisqu'il
d'après les premières estimations et les
il a été réélu il devrait être réélu à
son
son poste de président de région alors
il a très certainement pu compter 1
xavier bertrand sur le report des votes
de laurent pietra faisait ce qui est le
candidat de la majorité présidentielle
le candidat de la république en marche
qui était arrivée quatrième la semaine
dernière au premier tour avec 9,1 pour
cent alors il a rapidement reconnu sa
défaite en laurent pied travailler ce
qui est il a tout de suite appelé à
voter en faveur de xavier bertrand alors
si on se fie aux résultats aux dernières
estimations et bien on peut tout à fait
dire un sans difficulté que le bilan du
premier mandat du président sortant est
bien a convaincu les électeurs
il se félicite xavier bertrand il s'est
fini c'est tout tout au long de la
campagne électorale
d'ailleurs de son bilan à la tête de la
région des hauts de france et notamment
dans les secteurs de l'emploi et de la
santé alors l'ancien ministre de jacques
chirac et de nicolas sarkozy se
positionne très vite maintenant elle
pense tout de suite il va très
certainement se mobiliser à partir de
demain et les semaines à venir à vers
2022 et l'élection présidentielle
puisqu'il s'est déjà porté candidat il
estime être le candidat à droite le plus
à même de d'amorcer un retour de la
droite dans les plus hautes sphères de
l'état lui qui est bien à la volonté
l'objectif le désir d'aller rapidement à
la rencontre de tous les français je
vous propose de l'écouter
merci l'histoire de bardos ici sur les
rayonnements sont fidèles série d la
france
le front national
et il avait
ces histoires uniques
ce soir je veux m'adresser
ac franchise
on
[Musique]
c'est le lieu
michel etc
[Musique]
et ses propos xavier bertrand les a
tenus quelques minutes seulement après
20 heures après l annonce et des
premières estimations il les a tenus
devant la presse bien sûr mais aussi
devant une cinquantaine de militants
venus écouter et bien le président
sortant de la région les féliciter
d'avoir voté pour eux et je vous propose
justement d'écouter quelques militants
qui est bien entretenu a félicité xavier
bertrand pour sa réélection
je pense que vous avez bertrand sait
vraiment qui saura écouter les français
en colère qui ne se sont pas déplacés
pour aller voter
lui même dit dans son discours et c'est
ce qui est important c'est bien c'est ça
c'est d'écouter pas mépriser les
français vous avez bertrand ça sera très
bien faire réunir les français
ces sommes il se dit gaulliste et du
gaulliste social et c'est ça être beau
lycée rassembler un maximum de français
autour du de son projet à très heureuse
très heureuse pour lui très heureuse
aussi pour les habitants de la région
alors moi je suis maire de saint-quentin
je lui ai succédé
je sais combien c'est un combattant
combien il a foi dans ce qu'ils
proposent aussi combien il s'est
représenté les habitants puis à saint
quentin sur ses terres il fait un très
beau score de plus de 65% la majorité
absolue dans tous les bureaux de vote
donc vraiment les gens lui font
confiance ici dans les hauts de france
je peux vous dire que c'est le meilleur
puisque quand vous regardez les
résultats c'est plutôt même si elles
beaucoup d'abstention mais en général
abstention fait monter le fn
ici ça pas été le cas et pour tout vous
dire oui quand je regarde le paysage
politique aujourd'hui avec nos hommes et
nos femmes fort - oui xavier bertrand
est clairement l'homme de la situation
pour le national puisque puisqu'il
rassemble surtout il rassemble de tous
bords et aujourd'hui
je pense que les gens ont besoin de
retrouver cette proximité je pense que
xavier pourrait très bien faire le job
ce qu'il a fait en région le reproduire
sur la nationale on est clairement vous
aviez bertrand a quitté l'est
républicain il ya trois ans et pourtant
il estime être le plus à même d'amener
la droite vers la victoire pour 2022
sauf qu'il y a du monde au portillon
valérie pécresse qui devrait être réélu
elle aussi à la tête de la région d'île
de france tout comme laurent wauquiez
dans la région auvergne rhône-alpes ils
estiment tous les deux être tout aussi
légitime de tout aussi légitime que et
xavier bertrand pour représenter la
droite alors ne parlez pas de primaires
à droite xavier bertrand n'en veut pas
il sait déjà désigné comme étant le
candidat le plus à même d'amener la
droite vers la victoire
quoi qu'il en soit les discussions les
échanges les débats devraient être
certainement très mouvementée à droite
au cours des prochains mois merci
beaucoup à vous nadège abderrazak en
direct du qg de xavier bertrand va vous
retrouver tout à l'heure pour faire un
nouveau point sur l'atmosphère sur place
et tout